[Music]
buying games digitally means you don't
have to put on pants and go to a store
and that's exactly how a bunch of people
got theirs in 2016 but which ps4 games
were downloaded the most thanks to the
PlayStation Blog we know the best of the
best I'm Matt and this is your digital
only gamespot news updates coming in at
number 10 is EA's annual soccer game
FIFA 17 while the number 9 spot is held
by the spacefaring no man's sky next is
battlefield 4 in the eighth spot
gamespot's game of the year overwatch at
number 7 and despite releasing in 2014
grand theft auto 5 at number 6 the top
five starts with a division in fifth
place call of duty infinite warfare and
forth and minecraft and third despite
being the number one downloaded game on
ps3 second place honors go to
battlefield one but the most downloaded
ps4 game of 2016 is the excellent soccer
with cars game rocket league head on
over to gamespot if you want to check
out the rankings of a bunch of different
categories including ps3 Vita and
PlayStation VR but for more news from
the world of video games you're already
in the right place